hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the
difficult experiences that nearly all of
us have to suffer at one time or another
is getting sick and you know this can
range over a whole variety of illnesses
of the body and it might even include
you know some things that we call mental
illnesses as well could be lumped in
here Epictetus for example we'll talk
about melancholy and and you know the
need to be able to deal with that
understanding that as sort of a disorder
of the humors in any case this is this
is something that the Stoics devoted
some thought to because it's such a
commonplace experience not only in their
time when many people in fact item
illnesses but in our time when people
again also draining illnesses quite a
bit they're just different illnesses
we've managed you and now calculate
children against a number of different
diseases as a matter of fact even wiped
some of them out more or less that used
to be pretty terrible but you know we
inhabit a world in which some of the big
killers now are things like heart
disease or cancer or diabetes
you know diseases that were not quite so
prevalent when people
live so long cancer is a you know
particularly good example the fact that
we have extended their lifetimes by
eliminating some diseases has perhaps
opened us up to to others and so you
know we're going to the sooner or later
died of something many of us are going
to die of illnesses of one form or
another and even if we don't die of
illnesses we often have to suffer with
them you could think of people who spend
you know a good portion of their life
with rheumatoid arthritis which can
strike you know when you're a young
person and then continue on for years
and years there's there's many diseases
that that really put a damper on our
life but then there's all these acute
diseases as well you know we get a cold
we get the flu we get a fever as
epictetus is going to talk about there's
all sorts of things we can contract that
really you know to a lot of us either
ruin our lives or certainly reduce the
quality as we say of life so how did
that photo Stoics think that we want to
deal with illnesses illnesses of the
body now the Stoics understand that
illness is one of those things that's
outside of our power in large partners
there's a bit to say about that in just
a moment and it's typically seen by most
people as a bad thing
the Stoics think that that is a mystique
and judgment that illness is not
something good or bad it's just
something that is it's an indifferent
what we make of it is what makes it good
or bad for us and that has to do with
our reactions now when they say that it
is something that lies outside of our
power that doesn't mean that they had a
totally fatalistic attitude about it for
example you can see that mattias and
what before in his discussion of
cleanliness saying it's important to do
hygiene you know not just so you don't
stink and bother other people around you
but also so that you keep your body in
in good repair ease as your body is like
a horse if you were given a horse you
would not take care
would you and then you know expect it to
be in good condition no you actually
have to attend to it take care of it so
you need to maintain some standards of
hygiene and you know some standards of
cleanliness
the Stoics would be for people doing
exercise the Stoics would be for
preventive medicine
the thing that the Stoics would stress
though is you can do all of that and
then still get sick you can get the flu
shot and you're inoculated against the
three strains of flu that the scientists
had decided are the most likely statists
to statistically to be the ones that
you're gonna run into and then you could
get any of the other 50 strains of flu
that are floating around out there you
can get the inoculation and it can that
work you can do all the preventive
medicine that you like and get sick with
something that got through the gaps
there's all sorts of things that can go
wrong and so you know we could even say
that about the medical treatment right
people go into hospitals and they're
going into the hospital to get cured or
whether they get to get a staph
infection because that's one of the
places one of the best places to get
such an infection and one of these
superbugs there is a lot that that
really does remain out of our control
some of it has to do with genetics a
great example of this is the recent
phenomenon women getting tested to find
out whether they have a propensity to
breast cancer and if they have a high
enough propensity actually getting a
mastectomy that does seem to be
something where they have some control
over what's happening with their body
but does that mean that they won't get
any sort of cancer it doesn't there's
you know all sorts of other things that
can happen so illness as a class is not
something that we can think that we can
stay while completely perhaps in the
future you know if some science fictiony
scenarios come true maybe we have to
rethink this but for the time being it's
very clear that even in the first world
with great medical treatment illness is
something that we have to deal with so
it's precisely according to the Stoics
one of those things that we want to
have practiced dealing with we ought to
have thought through what we're going to
do when we find out we've got some bad
news before that news hits so that we
can be armed against it and I mean I
would seem to this extends metal it's a
bad news for ourselves but also for
others for whom we feel concerned or
affection we should you know anticipate
that some of these things are going to
happen sooner or later so what can we do
we can on bear as he says our fever is
using that as an example or the hunger
or thirst that the doctor imposes upon
us 73 you've ever been in a hospital you
know that being in a hospital is not fun
in part because they don't want you to
do what you want to do what you watch as
much TV as you like but you can't get up
on your bed when you want to you you
know you have to check in with people
they won't give you you know whatever
you want to eat or drink and so the
question is how do we handle those sort
of things we can bear those in the right
way and what is it the right way well
for the stone it's keeping our ruling
faculty in accordance with nature that's
the general answer in pretty much every
case that epictetus is going to get
right we can use the external conditions
of illness which is something that
affects their body and the responses to
illness which can sometimes be even
worse right we can use those in the
right wing keeping our ruling faculty in
accordance with nature what does that
mean in greeley well he gives us some
examples he says if you have a fever in
the right way you perform the things
expected of the man who has a fever not
expected in the sense of like we're
doing disaster preparation and thinking
about hysterics and the sort of things
that they'll do rather what is the best
way a person would react that a person
who really has it together
how will they deal with their medical
emergency their medical problem their
medical crisis so he goes on he says
well what does it mean to have fever in
the right way not to blame God or man
not to not to be saying oh woe is me the
universe is turning against me why why
God so to understand that it's part of
the course of things he says not to be
overwhelmed by what happens to you to
wait death bravely and in the right way
to do what is enjoined it on you you
know not to tell your doctor get it go
screw himself when he when he wants to
do some some treatment provided your
doctor actually knows what he's doing
when your physician comes to see you not
to be afraid of what he will say and at
the same time not to be carried away
with joy if he says you were doing
splendidly for what good to you lay in
that remark when you were well what good
was a tear he says it means not to be
done hurted too if he says you're in a
bad way so he goes on he says is the
universe going to be upset when you die
why then do you wheedle your physician
why do you say if you wish master I
shall get well why do you give them
occasion to put on airs why not just
give him what is his due just treat the
doctor as a doctor that doesn't mean
that you you have to have you know sort
of differential attitude towards them
and you can't suggest maybe I heard
about this medical treatment over there
can we try that out there's a lot of
doctors who actually probably need a
good talking-to from time to time well
it's all about how you choose to do it
are you doing it out of a sense of
desperation or are you doing it because
it's you know what is expected and what
you want to do in that case you know all
things being equal it's better to stay
alive it's a preferred it different from
the stomach perspective but if your body
is going to die it's going to tell you a
choice about how you're going to die are
you going to go go
you know down as they say with your
boots on or are you going to you know go
down crying and you know wailing and
saying how unfair all of it is so he
goes I'm gonna give a lot of other
examples but then he says these are the
things the moment demands for a man is
in a fever if he meets this demands he
has what it properly belongs to him it's
not the business of the philosopher to
guard these external matters the wine
oil or even his body but what his
governing principle to keep it in
accordance with nature so that is how
epictetus thinks that we want to face
this you know in a difference of
sickness that we don't have complete
control over we can we can take some
steps to eliminate some probabilities
but we could still get sick I want to
say one other thing about this as well
in other chapters of these books of the
discourses he is going to talk about
illness as an example and you might
think that that patinas would as a stoic
be telling everybody hate lock up and
act stoic about your illness he's not
doing that actually because it doesn't
do any good to tell somebody who's not
ready to hear that then they should just
shut up and you know not be consoled or
not being nourished or anything like
that as a matter of fact he has this
example of the the official who comes to
him and his daughter is sick and he left
the room he got out of there because he
couldn't stand to see her suffering and
Epictetus says well there's something
really wrong with you buddy why did you
abandon your child and the man says oh
it was out of my affection for her
and Epictetus says that's not parental
affection at all do you know who
displayed parental affection your wife
who's named the child
the nurse who stated to the child the
kids tutor who stayed with the child
all of them stayed with her and consoled
her in her illness and they didn't say
I'm going to take care of myself I can't
stand the CEO you know I I can't bear to
be in the room and so they did what they
needed to do and show some solidarity
and showed some support and some
compassion so notice that epictetus
doesn't say well you should have also
told her you know that that being ill
and being sick is been different he's
not worried about that
he thinks that when a person who you
know isn't on the stomach path is
experiencing these things they very well
may think that it is a terrible calamity
that's the following
then you commiserate with them not to
the extent that you allow yourself to
become totally upset by it but so that
you can help them out now if you are
getting sick and you actually are trying
to practice the stoic philosophy that
you should try to keep your faculty you
know your your rational faculty and your
faculty of choice in accordance with
nature
likewise if your friend and I suppose or
your spouse is trying to practice
stoicism or who's trying to do
philosophy and take a philosophical
attitude then you could remind them that
illness is not the evil that we believe
it to be but you know they're suppose
you would say if if you do that and they
have a very bad reaction to it perhaps
you should back off and just be there to
take care of them so this is how
epictetus thinks about illness this very
common thing that we think to being evil
that from a stoic perspective actually
isn't an evil